[Music]
boom right off the bat I would say that
the packaging is significantly more fun
than I thought it would be smaller gonna
linguas een food gift from the people of
the United States of America one meal
ready to eat
oh is that what MRE stands for meal
ready to you I mean it looks like I
shrank and got a chocolate bar nutrition
a force multiplier for seeing coffee oh
I don't even like coffee anyway animal
crackers a camel you get a camel that's
too easy I can already tell it's gonna
be the worst cracker I ever read in my
life I'm sorry I opened this I love how
you have your sweet your savory cracker
option Oh hmm looks like a space food
I'm just confused as to the lack of
plate I love me some niacin Santa Fe
style beans and rice this doesn't sound
bad if you read the ingredients though I
don't know how I feel about cardboard
meet individual flameless ration heater
hmm this is the thing that makes the
magic happen that's it I just add water
yeah how come they can't just make a
fire oh because that would alert the
enemies there's a lot of science going
on in this pack of food - oh I think I
did too much I do hear some crazy [ __ ]
going on in here it's making noises why
is it making noises Oh
oh my god oh that's so I would do this
at home just like at a party just like
yo you guys want those meal bags what's
up how I like a straw like it's like a
Hawaiian Punch you know you have to be
away from my family and stuff for years
secretly the hardest part is opening
your food doesn't smell bad actually I
would definitely like mix this stuff
with like some Fritos but there's like a
little spice to it it's not the worst I
feel the people can save the world on
this it actually smells pretty good I'm
pretty impressed it's a little weird
eating out of a pouch I'm not gonna lie
I think this is my life for today I've
never even thought of what a soldier
would eat they never show that it's a
difficult situation to be in and food is
probably one of the last things I'm
thinking about
even though it's kind of silly and fun
to try I'm here it's pretty neat
especially in the conditions that they
were working in and some compared to
what we do for a living
maybe it's giving you a little bit more
of like an emotional push when you might
be somewhere way far from the Sante FES
- how try some
we can clearly tell I could never be a
soldier I just admire the ones who can
[Music]